bom hoje eu queria falar pra você
a trajetória desde a época que eu era
adulta até agora quando eu sou muito
criança eu vou explicar
quando eu era criança eu era muito séria
e muito adulta quando me perguntar o que
eu queria ser quando crescesse eu disse
que queria ser uma doutora de congresso
e acho que falar no ted de seu topo da
minha carreira que eu inventei as quatro
anos e esse lado sério é muito
importante pra ir a congresso é pra ir a
reuniões com reitores eleitores muitos
sérios praia fórum de pesquisa mas
alguma coisa foi acontecendo comigo e
aos poucos eu fui criança andando não
sei se foi no ambulatório de pediatria
se foi com meus alunos
brincando com minha filha mas foi
acontecendo e aí vocês terem uma idéia é
se o harry potter tivesse sido lançado
quando tinha oito anos ou sete anos eu
certamente teria dito ai que coisa de
criança que sem graça não quero nem
saber
hoje olha como é que eu sou então por
que isso é tão importante o que isso tem
a ver com cuidado porque o lado criança
me alimenta a empatia alimenta a
criatividade o lado criança faz com que
a gente fez as coisas de uma forma
diferente na janela de onde eu trabalho
em vez de ver um prédio eu prefiro ver
um submarino pronto pra zarpao submarino
amarelo e tem uma palavra grega pra isso
que as crianças fazem que é viver com a
alma colocar a alma no que a gente faz
essa palavra é merak e outra coisa que
eu acho que é muito importante é que a
criança tenha um espírito crítico como
criança muito lógica para aceitar as
coisas assim
sem questionar as crianças ensinam
coisas que pra mim pra todas as
profissões que eu escolhi de médica
pesquisadora e professora são
fundamentais que são aprender a aprender
e aprender desaprendendo porque eu estou
dizendo isso porque o que a gente
aprende
não quero assustar ninguém mas na área
da saúde a gente sabe muito pouco o que
a gente sabe é muito transitório a gente
nunca tem certeza de nada
o que a gente sabe hoje já não vai valer
amanhã o que o ensino para os meus
alunos no primeiro ano da faculdade já
não vai servir quando ele se formarem
então é muito mais importante
a gente aprender a aprender e buscar
informação saber onde ela está e como
avaliar criticamente essa informação do
que a gente decorar o motor de conteúdos
então o ensino para a saúde o ensino do
bem cuidado também tem que mudar
por exemplo eu trabalho com prevenção
cardiovascular e na minha área por muito
tempo se falou que por exemplo a
obesidade é uma questão de balanço entre
ganho calórico e gasto calórico que é
importante fazer uma dieta restritiva
evitar alguns alimentos por exemplo
gorduras e se focar nos alimentos diet
light
hoje a gente sabe que essas dietas muito
restritivas são até perigosas elas podem
não só engordar como causar problemas
bem maiores como transtornos alimentares
vão ficar estressado com um determinado
tipo de alimento pode só piorar a
situação
existem gorduras boas assim como existem
alimentos light muito ruins então é
muito importante a gente saber avaliar
criticamente formação em cada caso
a outra coisa que eu acho que é
importante a gente pensar nas variáveis
que a gente não estuda normalmente por
exemplo a dieta mediterrânea é
diretamente terrâneo é muito saudável em
vários estudos mostrando que ela é ótimo
só que será que é directamente terrana
funciona para uma pessoa que está
estressadíssima brigando no trânsito
xingando todo mundo tratando no face ou
será que a dieta mediterrânea funciona
porque lá os italianos os gregos e os
franceses ficam na mesa em volta da mesa
saboreando a vida curtindo os amigos
conversando passar o dia inteiro fazendo
alguma atividade física algum tipo de
movimento
a mesma coisa atividade física se você
passar oito horas sentado depois foi
correr uma maratona por obrigação pode
não ser a melhor coisa se você gosta de
correr ótimo vai correr mas se não gosta
vai brincar com o cachorro dançar pular
amarelinha que vai ser muito melhor
além disso talvez a gente esteja também
procurando novos padrões da normalidade
talvez o que a gente considerava como
normal pode não ser mais tão
normal talvez tenha um pouquinho de peso
a mais seja melhor termos de desfechos
reais de saúde para homens e mulheres
reais
então a gente tem que pensar se o que a
gente considerava normal antes era
normal em termos de saúde ou era só o
ideal estético que não é nem possível de
atingir na nossa sociedade
então por isso que eu digo que diz
aprender a aprender porque a gente está
sempre tendo que revisar e ressignificar
o que a gente sabe
então como diz o mestre yoda muito
aprender você tem e desaprender tudo o
que você aprendeu você precisa
essa é a base para ser cientista para
ser pesquisador vai ser profissional da
saúde e até pra vida né
[Música]
é eu acho que é bem importante que por
isso que eu decidi que é uma das minhas
missões na vida como professora é em
cima duvidar de tudo toda a ciência
precisa de pessoas que duvidem e se a
gente vê assim as informações que chegam
para nós porque a quantidade de
informações hoje enorme né gente vê as
informações isso aqui apareceu na minha
timeline está comprovado cientificamente
que quem não toma café com açúcar deve
ser psicopata então e comprovados
cientificamente então a gente precisa
saber se toda essa informação que chega
em nós é realmente verdadeira ser válida
se a gente vai utilizar ela na nossa
vida
então é a partir de dúvida por exemplo
nem a criança foi aquela que disse que a
roupa nova do rei de alguma coisa errada
então a china de duvidar duvidar que o
sol gira em torno da terra é que a gente
vai buscar um conhecimento novo e dentro
dessa questão do senso comum uma coisa
que sempre me ensinaram do senso comum é
que na época das cavernas os homens eram
mais fortes que carregavam as mulheres
pelo cabelo ea mulher toda frágil ficava
lá na caverna esperando e vence a que
fosse mais forte quem competia melhor e
se não for nada disso hoje tem muitos
estudos antropológicos que mostram que a
caçada ea coleta atividades coletivas e
que quando as mulheres em um carro
a junta o resultado era muito melhor do
que quando os homens que estavam
sozinhos
então será que a gente não tem que
repensar tudo que a gente aprendeu
inclusive tem um estudo bem interessante
que diz que aqueles grupos que cantavam
juntos antes aumentar a eficiência da
caçada então imagina se a gente é
resultado de uma seleção natural que
privilegia quem cantava junto e
colaborava em vez de competir eu
acredito realmente que a colaboração
leva muito mais longe que a competição
do ponto de vista de qualquer criança e
isso é muito fácil de entender
é muito mais fácil colaborar do que
gastar energia preocupado com o que o
outro está fazendo colaborando agente
potencializa as nossas habilidades nosso
conhecimento nosso tempo a nossa energia
os nossos saberes e tem uma palavra
tupi-guarani pra isso que motivou o
tirou é um mutirão para fazermos todos
juntos nos ajudando os outros em nome do
bem comum bom colaboração me leva a
pensar em empatia empatia
eu queria contar uma história que
aconteceu comigo eu me considero uma boa
motorista mas esses tempos eu tive que
pegar um carro emprestado que eu não
conhecia que é bem diferente do que eu
estava acostumado
e aí nos primeiros 15 minutos eu fiz o
roriz
eu freei bruscamente eu andei a 10 por
hora e eu levei um monte de xingamentos
e buzinas no trânsito
e aí eu fiquei pensando eu mereci todos
eles porque estava dirigindo muito mal
mas eu fiquei pensando como é difícil se
colocar no lugar do outro né
como é difícil pensar em uma pessoa
fazendo coisa estranha será que ela está
bem
será que ela recebeu uma notícia triste
será que ela tá tendo uma crise de
lombrigas que está acontecendo com essa
pessoa é muito mais fácil pensar eu sou
melhor motorista vou xingar eu vou
passar reto e pensando nisso em termos
de quem ensina como importante para o
professor entender que o aprendizado é o
desconforto a gente tem que sair da
nossa zona de conforto inicialmente para
poder aprender
depois que a gente consegue uma
maravilha mas nesse momento de
desconforto é muito importante ter um
professor que acolhia é isso que nos
ajude que trilha o caminho junto e não
que acrescente mais percorrer esse
processo
também do ponto de vista do encontro
entre a pessoa que busca ajuda e o
profissional da saúde é importante
aprender que ninguém ninguém aprendeu a
ficar doente é uma situação de
desconforto que a gente precisa ser
acolhido e isso é o que se chama de boom
tu uma palavra de raiz banco que quer
dizer difícil de traduzir mas quer dizer
eu sou porque nós somos não existe uma
conexão entre todos nós e por causa
dessa conexão entre todos nós
eu resolvi aprender uma outra coisa já
era boa motorista de carro mas resolvi
aprender a dirigir um ônibus um ônibus
enorme cheio de passageiros que se chama
universidade porque eu resolvi fazer
isso porque eu achei que nesse momento
era o melhor cuidado que eu poderia
oferecer porque todos nós somos esse a
gente acredita que uma coisa pode mudar
tá na hora de arregaçar as mangas e
fazer
eu acho que essa hipótese é maluca de
que a excelência acadêmica pode conviver
com felicidade e que amor não deveria
ser uma palavra estranha na academia eu
acho que felicidade
a gente pode fazer as coisas com muita
seriedade mas se a gente fizer com muita
seriedade e ao mesmo tempo pensar no
nosso lado criança isso não precisa ser
uma coisa chata então se a gente tiver
uma universidade que é muito boa
tecnicamente mas que a gente possa ser
feliz
ela vai ser quase como uma escola de
magia imaginem uma escola de saúde onde
a gente possa ter aula de empatia de
amor aula de abraço aula de cuidado com
o próximo à aula de auto-cuidado imagine
um lugar onde as crianças possam ser
colhidos uma universidade que possa se
abrir para a comunidade onde a gente
possa fazer pesquisa que possa ser útil
para as pessoas que possam melhorar a
vida das pessoas
imagine pensar no nosso planetinha azul
em movimento consciente em compaixão em
gratidão outras variáveis que quase
nunca ninguém considera dentro da
academia
imagine tudo isso imagine se a gente não
precisa esperar nem um segundo para
começar a mudar o mundo quem disse essa
fase
uma criança anne frank muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]